find his website let can we we should
call as
you should call him and say you're fired
because you're gay okay
find his number call him right now tell
me
why not because we're recording without
his consent just tell him you're
fired because you're gay he can't sue us
he won't even show up
this looks like his he's a contributor
to this website and this must be it
i i don't know doesn't he have a website
this looks like it's it
that's not his website
just write lawyer lawyer
there's a couple different lawyers with
his name is the problem he's not like
he's the biggest
that's what le yeah there he is there he
is
yeah right there okay call him call him
from your phone
call him right now and tell him that
you're fired because you're gay let me
find his phone number
say i was fired because i'm gay
oh his license is inactive call him
anyway
no phone number here yeah there was a
phone number
if you go back up go back up yeah
yeah he litigates claims of employment
discrimination
including ones he makes up
he literally he would tell me he'd go
yeah not every one of them gets fired
for being gay but you know who knows
we don't know why they were fired we
just uh you know
we just say it's because the ceo you
know the boss hates gay people
okay i'm gonna call this right here yeah
call that
call that you go i was fired from sonic
because i'm gay
tell him let me connect this
tell him i was fired from sonic because
i'm gay my friend i met a friend uh
my drag queen friend said you helped me
okay i have to let him know i'm
recording
what's hello first
and then what's my story you're fired
from welcome to verizon wireless
the number you dialed has been changed
disconnected or is no longer
dude he doesn't have a business anymore
dude i think he might just be smoking
krill
let me see if i still have him i may
still have him
i don't think so okay i was fired from
sonic for being gay
yeah hi justin
he may know who you are oh really i
don't know
are you gonna hop in at any moment
your call has been forwarded to an
automatic voice message system
yeah just leave a message
is not available at this time at the
tone please record your message
when you have finished recording you may
hang up or press one for more options
hi justin you don't know me i got your
phone number from a friend
i was fired from sonic because i came
out to my co-workers and my manager
thought that was disgusting and he's
like bigoted so he basically threw me in
the streets and
now i don't have a job and i really need
a good attorney to represent me here
um stop um
stop stop so um anyway uh if you could
get back to me
just put it and um i've just been
discriminated against
and uh anyway oh my god you're so tired
thank you so much
it's not it's not stupid it's his job
it's his fake job so he can now do it
and call you back because you were fired
from sonic yeah it's your [ __ ] job